[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
[Music]
hit one to me
thank you
today is monday june 20th and bert
cricher is putting on the biggest and
best comedy tour
of all time i mean this thing has
everything it seems so [ __ ] fun i
want to go so bad it's at nascar
racetracks and minor league baseball
stadiums and it's day drinking and
tailgating and sunsets and comedy and
it's everything that bert is in himself
this is the most burt krishna brunt
christler tour of all time and i'm so
excited to get more into it in this
video welcome back to the fourth episode
of the joke world comedy update every
single monday bring you the comedy news
that you need whether it be new tours
new specials who's going on each other's
podcast the last week everything you
need to know about comedy and comedians
and stand up and podcasting so you don't
miss a thing joke world every single
monday subscribe now and this audio will
also be on spotify if you feel like
supporting the channel and want to
download that would really help us out
but let's get back to it the burke
chrysler fully loaded tour the uh fully
loaded tour this is what the website
describes a fully loaded tour as
this summer for two weeks in june i'll
be bringing eight cities a comedy
festival like you've never seen before
i'll be taking my friends the top comics
in the country to amphitheaters arenas
raceways and minor league stadiums
bringing you the summer's biggest laughs
coldest beers sunsets music and a ton of
surprises trust me you won't want to
miss out this lineup is fully loaded
baby so that's what the fully loaded
festival website has now let's look at
this lineup that they've been bragging
so much about i'm sure it'll be a great
lineup oh it's dave attell joey diaz
shane gillis mark norman big j brian
simpson nikki glazer chelsea lynn and
fortune feamster
oh and sal volcano taylor tomlinson
aaron weber i mean dude they need to do
this for more than eight venues in two
weeks this lineup is nuts this is this
lineup is nuts to see that in like a
minor league baseball stadium when
you've just been day drinking with the
boys all day and then you go mark norman
to shane gillis to big j to joey diaz
dave attell all what dude
come on i need to go to this tour so bad
so the city's that's coming to if you
can still make it june 23rd is in south
carolina that one's sold out in
greensville then the 24th is in bristol
tennessee that still has tickets the
25th in georgia is sold out and then the
26 in missouri
that's still
that sells tickets so there's only four
shows left two of them are sold out so
good luckening tickets the one in
georgia i want to give a quick shout out
to my dude kevin gardner he hit me up on
instagram and he's like dude send me
some joke world stickers i want to pass
them out at the bert fully loaded tour
explain a little bit about the channel
be a little bit of an ambassador to you
guys and that's the coolest [ __ ] that
anyone's ever hit me up about shout to
you kevin going to this awesome tour and
handing out some joke world stickers and
spreading the word of the channel dude
everyone that follows this page we're
all on the same team team joke world so
kevin garner shout out to you for you
know just getting the message out there
and repping the brand and being a great
teammate
but honestly this tour looks like a
blast i've never heard of just like such
a fun
summery you know comedy event and it
makes sense that bruce was the one to
put this all together because everything
about this is such up his alley i would
go recommend checking out his instagram
now that the tour is already kicked off
like it just looks like so much fun and
as someone who just loves drinking and
laughing and having a good time like uh
this seems like the dream so shout out
to the burke reicher fully loaded tour
coming to maybe a city near you if it's
not already sold out but it seems like a
ton of fun seems like a total blast go
see it it's a it's in a bunch of like
minor league baseball parks an
amphitheater it's it's got
bert attel diaz fortune shane gillis wow
nikki glazer uh chelsea lynn mark norman
big j okerson taylor tomlinson sal
volcano wow it's like a full showcase
that's a big show and that it'll be like
um
you know outdoors and probably people
doing like 20 minutes and
they're gonna have
it's gonna be like super fun
entertaining
you know
side things happening and it'll be it'll
be a fun night snoop dogg just entered
the comedy scene dropping a stand-up
special on netflix it was called snoop
dogg's [ __ ] around special and it was
basically just like him hosting this
show and snoop's a funny likable guy and
he's not really doing stand-up he's just
kind of talking and saying what the show
is going to be and then he brings up a
few of his comedian friends like kat
williams donald rawling mike epps it's
definitely made for a black audience and
netflix even says that like that's what
a lot of the jokes and conversation is
centered around but it will be
you know snoop kind of hosting bringing
up a black comic and then interviewing
not even interviewing just kind of
lamping with them afterwards you know
they're smoking and drinking and just
just having conversations how you doing
man how you feeling oh i'm hot
i mean it it's not a comedy special at
all
but it's it's nice that they call it
that i guess it was another thing that
they they filmed at the netflix as a
joke comedy festival the bill byrne
friends and then the p davidson and
friends and now the snoop dogg and
friends were three events that they just
had at their festival
put cameras on and then threw on their
platform so
i have no problem with snoop dogg you
know
helping comedy and hosting a show he's
obviously one of the biggest names in
the world and and you know loves comedy
and cat williams and donnell rawlings
are huge comedians and it's nice they're
on netflix but as to netflix
specifically like how lazy can you get
to this is the third thing you put out
in three weeks that was part of a
festival that you charge money to
to attend you sold tickets to this
festival and then we're just like oh we
could throw some cameras in the back and
then also make money on this on our
platform and none of the three have been
good
bill burn friends was trash pete
davidson and friends was trash the snoop
dogg in france was trash none of these
things were good and you could have
allocated all that money to a real
stand-up special um
it's just kind of weird of netflix that
they keep doing this from their one like
are we just gonna see stuff from the
festival all year long then why would we
ever attend the festival netflix ain't
no [ __ ] joke huh yeah
the guest list is where we go through
some popular comedy podcasts the week
before see who was a guest on each show
to make sure that you don't miss any of
your favorite comedians appearing on
different shows so we're going to start
off with theavonne and this past weekend
they had on a country singer parker
mccullum tiger belly head on bruce
kirschner uh your mom's house did not
have a guest this week two bears won
cave burt was out as the co-host so they
had on ron white so two bears one cave
this week is tom segura and ron white
one of my personal favorite podcasts
that came out this past week so they put
drug dogs on the plane well of course i
smoked pot on the plane so the dogs are
all right
i don't know what that's
all about but
and then the guy goes uh the dog needs
to sniff that bag on your shoulder and i
was like
flagrant had on stavros and then they
also had on logan paul last week which
is two great guests obviously savros
speaks for himself but then logan paul a
lot of people might be like i don't know
it seems kind of like a doucher to me i
don't know if i'm gonna check that out i
would check it out dude he's he's
more chill than you think he is uh
whiskey ginger had arisha shafir on uh
kill tony head on fakim anwar which he's
going to be a guest coming up on the
joke world podcast soon so definitely go
check that out joe rogan didn't have any
comedians on this week it was just like
military guys and like
real officials like too real of
conversation for me to get a part of but
tom segura
went on part of my take last week i
don't know if we have any other fellow
barstool fans or awls that listen to
this channel but i love pmt and i love
tommy buns so i would definitely go
check out tom sagor on par my take it
was hilarious i love sports and all that
kind of thing too so that's right up my
alley and hopefully it is for you too
the other thing he would do is um
he would call share a bunch of thoughts
about you know you know cancel culture
right and like go on like a 10 minute
thing
and you go okay this is like an
interesting conversation i'll be like
well you know one of the things that i
think he'd be like all right well i love
you buddy i'll go hey man like
you think i'm just recording the call or
something like i thought this was going
to be a back and forth he didn't really
do that he just wanted to get it off his
chest it was always here are my thoughts
as far as new comedy specials go there
hasn't been really much in the past week
to talk about you still have the pete
davidson and friends on netflix now and
then we also talked about the snoop dogg
[ __ ] around special which i mean i feel
like maybe i was a little too harsh on
earlier it's fine
and i say it's fine
in that tone of voice because you could
see so much
better comedy on youtube and that's why
i feel weird being like go check out
snoop dogg's netflix special when it's
like
this is just worse than like what you
could find with like
shane gillis's youtube special or or
mike cannons or stavros's or joe lists
or you know so many guys so
not a lot in specials this week but
coming up the pipe as far as joke world
goes we got mike cannon on wednesday on
the joke world podcast so make sure you
go check that out every single wednesday
we're coming out with the joke world
podcast and it would mean a lot if you
guys can support that just like you guys
have been blowing up the news channel
every single monday i really appreciate
you guys watching these comment if you
see anything going on that i'm missing
that you're like hey we would really
like you to nail down this or this is a
gap that i feel like i don't know about
in the comedy world right now i need you
someone to talk about this dude let me
know i'm down for the people you guys
are my boys
and i want you know to give you guys the
best product available so tell me what
i'm missing tell me what you guys want
to hear about and i'll make sure it gets
done other than that thank you for
watching make sure you subscribe go
check out our instagram if you want any
free stickers shout out to the dude
putting out the stickers on bert's tour
for me and i'll see you guys next monday
[Music]
you